is this the last resting place of kidnap
victim Muriel Makai remote jaywick sands
on the Essex Coast
53 years ago Mrs Mackay was held for
ransom by Two Brothers they were later
jailed for her Murder She was never seen
again
it's now emerged that one of the
brothers Arthur Hussein claimed he
buried her on jaywick Sans his solicitor
revealed the Killer's confession in a
letter to the appeal court in 1972 he
said he told local police
but author Simon farker who discovered
the letter hidden in legal documents
doubts anyone followed up the
information
as far as I can tell no police officers
was ever given this information there
was no visit to see Arthur in prison
either by the police or by that
solicitor this is the only piece of
paper amongst thousands of pieces of
paper which actually name a possible
burial placement Mrs Mackay was the wife
of newspaper executive Alec Makai she
was abducted from their London home just
after Christmas in 1969 her kidnappers
mistook her for Anna the then wife of
Rupert Murdoch Mr makai's Boss
earlier this year police reopened the
case and searched the Hertfordshire Farm
where the Hussein Brothers kept Mrs
Makai prisoner they found no trace of
her
I learned to live with it a long time
ago the loss of my mother and the way it
happened so I don't really want to go on
and on forever but if someone's willing
to have a quick look or a proper look
for us on this huge area
maybe that's a good idea
there's no evidence that any police have
ever searched here for Muriel Makai and
certainly her family were never told of
the solicitors letter nor it seems were
detectives on the case and today
Scotland Yard is reluctant to start a
new search
the officer now in charge of the case
has dismissed the claim as one single
strand of intelligence with the killer
and his solicitor dead he said he can't
validate the information
Martin brunt Sky News Essex